welcome to a new episode of not too deep
I'm grace Helbig
we got Felicia Day she's back you've
heard her on the podcast before but
she's got more things going on so we're
talking to her all about it she's got a
new book out her child that came out of
her body is getting older and is
[ __ ] in inappropriate places and
it's really forcing her into some
unfortunate but hopefully like character
building situations you'll hear all
about it on this episode of not too deep
with Felicia Day hey you with the great
idea that I bet you want to turn into a
reality well I got someone that's going
to help you out
it's Squarespace they make it easier
than ever to launch your passion project
with they're showcasing your work or
selling products of any kind they have
beautiful templates and the ability to
customize just about anything so you can
easily make a beautiful website for
yourself and if you get stuck they have
24/7 award-winning customer support that
is there to help you out
head to squarespace.com slash Grace for
a free trial and when you're ready to
launch use the offer code grace to save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain you have one fortune cookie
just like one is that yours we'll get to
that later we will handle that ever
later moment before this in a noisy way
no it's great
okay I samaram at all cool I do this a
lot is that annoying that I well that's
the weird thing is that I'm not an ASMR
person but some like there's little
moments of like mouth noises that are
kind of soothing that I get I think
maybe I'm developing it as I go
is your yeah older you're just like I
need people to smack in my ear well you
know when you're taking photos with
people and you're taking selfies you
hear each other's mouths move no yeah
that's not my are you into SM are at all
in general no I like to make fun of it
yeah I mean I understand that it serves
a purpose for people but I don't get the
tingles it doesn't work on me yeah no
but I'll start doing it I'd stream on
Twitch like weekly for fun yes and then
I'll go
hey let's kill this little ogre and then
people get really turn
I'm super right there's a line I feel
like when it's used as a relaxation tool
versus it's used as like someone's
getting a boner now I don't want to heat
I don't want to imagine med I don't want
imaginary boners in my life you've had
too many years of that hey I know how
many boners I've created only you know
you've created a lot of boaters like
your look you're a boner moment I've
billion well here's what I feel like
you've had this really wonderful like
transcendence of just like slightly and
correct me if I'm wrong like not giving
as much of a [ __ ] but like owning
everything that you're doing and loving
everything that you're doing nothing you
weren't before
but like you being a mom being someone
that like just says I want a live stream
I want to write this book I want to be a
mom like these are the only things I
want to do right now and I'm really Yolo
right now are you yeah I mean today that
way this morning I just got an email
that a company passed on this TV show
that I've been pitching and I really
didn't care really I lit for the first
time I was like they're dumb I don't
know that was a dumb reason to pass
yeah and it's a great show and if
somebody doesn't want to make it then I
guess I'll do it as a book or I'll just
not do it like I'm I've kind of unhooked
myself from the Hollywood yoke in a way
where I could just go open a coffee shop
in Seattle and be happy with myself
that's how I feel constantly that I'm
like I could I start an Etsy shop it'd
be real bad but I could spin it and
maybe be very fulfilled by live in a
smaller town and like I could do a
community Orchestra it would be fun
because I'm just as good a person if I'm
there as if I'm like on the charts
quote-unquote short-sell in the projects
it's just barf but it must be like an
actual relief to like give yourself
permission to go I don't really like
that's kind of okay that that happened I
think it's it's like my lifelong journey
for approval and getting verified that
I'm an actual good humidor yeah it is
it's it's like I didn't realize how much
driven I was in my whole life oh just
like I want people to like me I want
people to approve of me I want to be
fancy so other people be impressed with
me like my
resume to be like what people like
actually think is interesting about I
needed a party to be like hi what are
you doing here's my twelve projects I'm
like but it must be I mean your your
your your child your kid now is two
years old she's a kitten she's good yeah
you're the kitten that you birth this
year's oh no she's two and a half and
she's like a real human being yeah I saw
you tweeting about how she's bringing
you like gluten free eight apple puree
or some [ __ ] okay yeah she brought me a
pouch like those little pouches that you
drink you applesauce out of and she's
like mama I got this on my work trip it
was from Paris it's gluten free she
literally said those words I promise
what and I was like did she go on a work
trip no I work trips a lot so that was
her impersonating you yes she's also
like whenever you sit and say oh look at
that painting isn't that pretty I did
that and I'm like I don't know how to do
I don't want to discourage her like
that's lying but I like that you think
that you could have that level of
artistry yeah I'm just like oh that's
cool I just got to pass it up I don't
know if that's good parenting I don't
know how to deal with that situation I
don't want to correct her because I'm
like oh and then I'm crushing her right
right so then I'm just breeze past it
I'm like oh that's nice hair do you want
a you know a popsicle well that seems so
bonkers to me I mean I'm sure you get
criticism because you're a parent now in
this world from everyone because you
exist online and that's the place where
everyone puts their opinions onto
everything constantly I feel like I
don't wear it I don't I don't use her as
a vehicle for my online gratification I
mean I pit moats alike for pictures of
her and I think I've stopped forever
because she I don't want her to become a
warped weird approval seeking [ __ ] like
I have been my whole life that's that's
very healthy I want her to be a tad more
healthy so I'm gonna make her unhealthy
in different ways for me there you go
by adverse route yeah and I think making
her a celebrity corner unquote when she
doesn't have like consent is kind of
icky to me like no judgement if you want
to post pictures of a child online the
way their own exactly but I don't unless
I'm getting a huge brand deal Gerber's
comes in like big she's pretty damn gear
she looks like a girl
no it was it is hard in this and
especially in this business right I'm
sure I don't know if you feel this but
as you age you feel like you're growing
out of an identity and yeah that
identity is your business and your
person your self-worth yeah
cuz that's what I wanted to talk to you
about a little bit I think we talked
about this a little bit last time but
the idea like when you go full force
into the internet you go full force and
you tend to be completely wrapped up in
like that to your identity yeah the way
you exist online and the business that
you carry online is your identity I for
sure felt in the last two years just
like pump the brakes like I don't really
know what I'm doing and I don't want to
force myself into something that just
because I fundamentally know this could
work in a trend way yeah exactly like
let's do this kind of prank thing let's
do some tide pod actually anything
that's popular I reject it normally but
it you know it is you you feel very
hemmed in and and it feels like this
goes into the book that you've just
written yes I just wrote a book
yeah it's called embrace your weird face
your fears and unleash creativity and
absolutely this whole book is kind of my
journey of trying to rebuild myself in a
more healthy way yeah and I think the
root of all that is creativity and I
really believe that everybody has an
inner creator that needs to have life
even if it's just having a hobby or an
outlet or if you become a professional
creator that's fine too but a lot of us
are very inhibited and don't let that
out and I think I wanted to do it in a
fun whimsical way in a book that was
kind of interactive so yeah oh wait so
there are like things in the book that
people can interact with the people like
like worksheets and like that like their
exercises yeah their exercise so I'll
talk about procrastination and then
there'll be an exercise or two about
like hey and they'll be fun and have
little graphics and or just space so I
want people to write in the book so it's
this weird hybrid that my editor was
like is this gonna work and then we were
like yeah this works yeah I mean it's
very like the artists way I think is a
really great like template for that
hundred percent it's without the god
stuff that's that's the logline I'm in
so heavy it's a little dramatic there's
fart jokes in this one there's weird
hoarded out unicorn drawing so yeah this
is literally the artists way got me here
lately I did that book maybe 15 years
ago when I first moved to LA and it
really got me on a path that led me to
here and so I revisited it a couple
years ago and I was like oh I can't
relate to this because there's a let's
there there's some great things in it
yeah there's a lot of like inner God and
like very sort of spirituality which
didn't connect with me at the time and I
was like let's do a funny one of these
like and it's my style like it's not
just that I I'm a self-help book addict
yeah I mean it's such a huge industry
it's instead like the I actually bought
the artist by like a year ago
like again cuz I did the same thing when
I lived in New York I bought it it was
really great very inspiring then I used
to prop up my air conditioning unit and
I got totally wet but then I bought it
and the workbook like a year ago and
then just never touched it for some
reason I started to read like the
beginning and I think the same thing I
just felt like I'm not connecting with
this yeah it's very much that sort of
like I'm going to Santa Fe to commune
with the crystals kind of vibe which is
totally fine as long as you engage with
that I just wanted to do one that was a
little nerdy or a little quirky or a
little funnier how did you did you test
out the worksheets or the interactive
parts on any friends or family
beforehand I mean I did that myself
like I I'm always like am I having fun
because I do want to do this checkbox
you know like and I I would just sit
down and be like what's the most primal
accessible funny way that I could do
this some of them are like just you know
some of them are more straightforward
just because I'm like I couldn't you
know yeah I couldn't trick somebody into
like delving into the memories but but
it's at the core of it like there's
always messages underneath when I'm
talking about it I do it in a very
personal way and then I try to make it
as funny as possible but you know this
is profound like if you can rediscover
who you are as a person
you can rediscover things that you want
and your that you want to put in your
life that can transform you like you can
truly transform you into a more happy
person and I'm not a cult leader this
creates cults God bless you with your
creativity
whatever happens happens yeah you're not
responsible for it you're not
responsible for called say yeah you know
I needed more internet than that I think
you have to be offline to be occultist
so or maybe just the first all I called
the pioneer of cults have you gone to
any like self-help retreats have you
done any of that world I tried to do a
silence whim but I left very quickly how
cuz my brother did the same thing for
his 30th birthday he thought he was a
little lost in his world and he's a very
intellectual guy and he signed up for
like a 10-day like so hardcore this was
just a weekend yeah he went full force I
was like oh you're having a weird time
at 30 vote yeah but yeah he said after
like day two he was kind of over it ya
know the weekend was torture I left that
night I was I mean listen like I think
I'm kind of a skeptical person I'm very
science-based and I do I mean I do
believe there are a lot of unconscious
things that we can attribute to the way
our brains work and things like that but
I don't think I'm being healed by
crystal I don't need to drink something
it made me vomit like there are a lot of
things that I do not believe that are
good for our body and unless I believe
in it then that's not going to work
exactly if it's placebo effect that's
great I just need to believe in it sure
if it was a donut retreat if we could do
donuts and pina coladas oh my god the
tree to get in touch with our inner
selves I am there how is that not your
actual book tour that you're about to go
on let's talk to your publishers and
change things around a little bit now
let's buff it up wait how did you decide
to go on this side of a tree it was it
just like I'm just doing this I it was a
lady support no listen I am here because
there was a lady support group in my
past yeah I created the guild I wrote
about this in my memoir where I was
doing such comedy and my teacher at the
time we came friends and because she was
in this group she was like come on every
week we're gonna share our wins and
losses in Hollywood it's amazing it was
great and it really spurred me to get
off my butt and write something because
they were actually productive and I was
just playing video games because the
guilt and peer pressure works there you
go so I can't you know I can't dedicate
any of that but you just I think you
just have to find what works for you and
I think in the process of doing the book
especially it's like
Oh everything's a process you have to
get to know yourself through work you
can't just be like oh I'm the person who
you know needs to be massaged to get my
inner spirit right I need to really be
trippin balls on some mushrooms that's
fine like you just have to try things
I'm not telling everybody to go do
mushrooms please it's every man for
themselves
woman them for themselves and you guys
can figure it out everyone has a
different process I feel like that's par
for the course is like testing out a
bunch of different things and seeing
what sparks your creativity and seeing
what like you're saying unlocks whatever
yeah is locked up in you that helps like
you understand yourself well and we have
to learn how to [ __ ] we deserve to have
fun yeah I mean for summary that like
it's I think it's schooling and stuff I
didn't go to school I was home-schooled
right and so I think a lot of us a lot
of people are just taught to only do the
bare minimum to get by mm-hmm and that's
especially for like learning and
exploring the world we're just like put
in these boxes and it'd be like get an A
and then move on I'm like we're not
really being taught to follow something
we love or find something we love and do
work that doesn't feel like work that's
true so yeah that's part of the book too
it's like get off your ass and do
something I'm sorry no that's don't be
sorry I think this is wonderful how
especially for someone that's had such a
career and then you know gets you get
wrapped up in and then you figure out
like [ __ ] I need to figure out like the
new phase of this career and how does
this work for me and especially having a
kid and all of that to be able to be
open and honest and like help people
figure out for themselves the way you
figure it out for yourself
yeah the bottom has to drop out for me
to make us change yeah like we're not
gonna change if we're slightly
uncomfortable right and I did that's so
true yeah I mean if I think we have to
go through like crisis we have to have
these moments where we're at a branch
we're like we are so incredibly
miserable that we'd do something to
about it yeah
or there's so many turtles being stuffed
up with plastic straws we outlawed them
like yes we have to be it has to be
drastic to get us to change and there
are certain life changes like getting
out of call you know going to college
getting out of college maybe turning 34
a lot of people having a baby like we're
taught you know I'm sure there's there's
benchmarks and I think we have a lot we
need a lot of extra care around those
transitions in our life totally and so I
wrote this book to try to help anybody
through any transition rediscover who
they are and
just try to find more fulfillment and
playfulness and their wife that's great
did you write this while you were
pregnant before after oh no I brought it
I wrote it this last winter into spring
and it was when I would turn that out I
I had to create I literally lost my mind
autumn fell out it was bad like Portugal
looks fine let's move there I like pay
to see all of your search history from
like December well I was weaning my baby
and I did not realize when I was in it
nobody talks about things that women
need to be talking about later
especially around pregnancy you kind of
like oh yep you got postpartum
depression right after you have a baby
no you're depressed for years yeah or at
least I was and when I started weaning
her like a lot of hormones went crazy in
my body for like eight months and I was
like literally and like it was really
rough in my business I mean I left my
business a couple years ago and I was
like trying to do Hollywood stuff and
yet I never fit in Hollywood it's never
gonna happen it's a it's a weird like
terrible I don't want to be part of it I
think I finally separated myself it
really took a lot of therapy and a lot
of like just getting my body back inside
myself and I literally wrote this book
kind of putting myself back together I
was like who the hell am i how do I
figure that out yeah what do I want to
do I have all these blocks that have got
like would spring up like
procrastination jealousy and all these
things and I'm like how do I deal with
all this stuff and like I just kind of
cobbled together in one book so I
realized after I wrote the book oh I
really really really grown up Wow so I
don't know hopefully or people just you
know do some sketching and I think that
message is great especially for a lot of
people that have lived online for a lot
of years and are feeling a very similar
myself type of burn out and like
rediscovery phase and like giving the
permission for this to be like a
conversation that's normalized and not
yeah like is it weird that we feel weird
well I think we have the sense of self
that gets very muddy and it's very very
very very aggravated by online and I
think if you imagine we had this little
glowy like stone in our hearts mm-hmm
the Internet makes us push that glow out
so it's
all just on our surface and then anyone
can punch it we are just an empty sad
show like what are those bunnies that
you get at the Rite Aid for around
Easter and we have nothing inside and I
think bunny after Easter is 10 cents
screw it I'll just stop its head in
right what about 10 cents shitty ass
buddy so then you're like I'm empty
inside what am i outside of being able
to be punched and then you're just like
you have to vacuum that soul back inside
whoa that's a beautiful weird visual
we're gonna take one quick break and
we'll be right back with more Felicia
Day and punch and bunnies but not you
know the metaphorical kind I bet you
have a dream that you'd like to turn
into a reality
am i right I'm right well guess what
Squarespace is here to help you out they
make it easier than ever to launch your
passion project do you want to start a
new business do you want to showcase
your work do you want to publish content
do you want to sell products or more
Squarespace is the tool for you they
have beautiful templates created by
world-class designers and the ability to
customize just about anything with a few
clicks so you can easily make a
beautiful website all by yourself they
have a powerful ecommerce functionality
that lets you sell anything online and
analytics that help you grow your site
in real time
everything is optimized for mobile right
out-of-the-box and there's nothing to
patch or upgrade ever buying domains is
simple and you'll get the help you need
with their 24/7 award-winning customer
support they empower millions of people
I'm talking about designers lawyers
artists gamers restaurants gyms they
help them turn great ideas into
something real so head to
squarespace.com slash Grace for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
use the offer code grace to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or
domain that's squarespace.com slash
grace / code grace as the creators have
clean Beauty bareMinerals is driven by a
philosophy that makeup and skin care
should make your skin better not just
better-looking and that's why their
best-selling original foundation is made
with only five ingredients guess what
they're all minerals for bare minerals
to be clean without com
for mais means good for skin formulas
with proven performance upgrade to the
clean beauty products use the foundation
finder at bare minerals calm to find
your perfect match and get 20% off when
you use the promo code not too deep bare
minerals the power of good trick
question would you rather go on vacation
with chrissy teigen or Oprah oh wow yeah
that's a hard one I know I don't even
know my actual answer for this because
Oprah the other day was going nuts about
cauliflower on Instagram wait what'd she
do just screaming about how it's
cauliflower moment is it cobblers moment
trendsetter because what if chrissy
teigen came out it's like no it's
asparagus season which one would you be
in tats the kind of online fighting that
I'm in confrontation that I'd like to
see I
I feel like Chrissy Teigen would be too
cool for me like all her musical
references everything she are friends I
would feel like I want to sit in a
corner and curl up and maybe cry Oprah I
feel like maybe there's a have friends
right yeah like she's all business like
maybe Gail would be there but they might
have like a pre-existing like to go to
I feel like Chrissy Teigen would be
creating so much more online content oh
then I would that I'd feel inferior of
like I don't even know how to Tik Tok I
downloaded it and did I haven't even
gotten that far you know I did and I was
like oh no you're too old out today I
don't care you don't care like my friend
has a puppet that's shaped like a toilet
roll paper perfect Charlet paper roll
toy li and i guess it's one of the first
stars of tic toc internet i think he has
a production deal though I'm not even
kidding
so and I've just been you know you and I
have been yeah I've been in this much
longer than you but like you see all
these phases of new platforms new trends
and it just becomes tiring because you
just are like oh okay I see the blip
that that will be and I'm leaving yeah
have you thought about cameo at all I
know everybody's trying to get me on
camera
and I'm like that's might literally pull
the ripcord if everything is falling to
[ __ ] if someone in my family gets super
sick and I need to support them like
yeah I will you'll see me on and know
that you you're only there because you
need it yeah me too
all right I don't think it will serve me
in any fulfilling creative way
whatsoever but you know I mean that's
what I think that's great about patreon
when you have a patreon you like yeah
well know they're supporting you you get
to have a club yeah it again says how
long have you been working on patreon
I've never had a patreon you don't I do
not have one because I've been putting
my [ __ ] in Hollywood thinking they're
gonna come out and be like that's a
great [ __ ] nobody's gonna be like
let's hire that [ __ ] finally after 20
years I've ignored her and her face and
even I'm not bitter no none of us are
bitter we're all fine but I'm literally
my dream is to be like a moon and
Portugal I'm gonna have a patreon and
I'm gonna twitch stream and I'm gonna
write stories and do a private yeah I
don't know how you're not already on
patreon that feels like because you
twitch which I don't fully understand
but I understand there is it's a
community base like yeah I don't have
any I have like a one-time fee for that
because I guilty that I couldn't be
there every week all the time but sure
it's fine I'm an idiot
I do support my child I took fan
conventions that's kind of the way that
I yeah you're out and about all the time
yeah so that's the way I've beat people
face-to-face and have people support me
like it's fine like that's it's fun for
me too I get to travel and so if I were
to get a ratchet that back I would do a
patreon also that's more creative so I
thinking about it maybe next year it's
it'll be there I feel like that's the
platform that is thriving right now and
it's like attracting a lot of people
that like you like myself and my memory
have our patreon yes it's a wonderful
way to build like a community that feels
like you said like a club yeah that's
what I miss that is always what I done
with my YouTube fell at when we first
started I feel like a little club that
we're all part of and that everyone that
was part of our part like was in this
like fun little group it was really a
good it was a good clique yeah it was a
community yeah and then they just fell
apart he got stabbed in the face
scared every time I like open a tab to
like click on YouTube do you watch no
things online at all nope I left YouTube
behind when I left my company and I have
literally I don't think I've watched a
video and really I mean I watched some
you know random little tiny things there
but I don't follow anybody in there
anymore it's just I mean I was always
kind of weird on that platform and I
made you know my stuff that could have
been anywhere and I always felt like an
outsider I always watched you and mamrie
and Hannah I was like they're so cool
like you starting a business going she's
so cool you know we should talk today I
mean we're all kind of hovering right
now maybe that's the world in which we
all come together it's all create an
island yeah if all of our rings combined
I think I mean there's a reboot to be
had I know irony a lot of people we're
gonna get into after this a lot of
Twitter questions but a lot of people
wanted to know about your music taste
mm-hmm well I have very little I
listened to the wheels on the bus go
round or like three little Ravens set on
us I mean you haven't gotten into the
baby shark hysteria no she doesn't
really like baby shark she's got
Calliope the only music I listen to I
listen to the podcasts because I really
like the only time I couldn't learn
something is in the car sure so I
listened to a lot of like ancient
history podcast cuz I like to have the
long view of how insignificant I am and
the scheme of existence that's really
exciting for me listen to children's
music and she is super super into
Halloween songs oh really
and that's January through October Oh
and then another January like everyday
it's a hundred Halloween song Wow how
did that happen I don't know and I don't
like it also how many Halloween songs
are there there's a cornucopia the worst
thing is when she's like I want
firefighter songs so then I have a whole
playlist of about 25 of those then she's
like I want doctor songs then I'll find
ten and then she's like I want a spider
doctor song many of them I'm like lady
there is a clearly an underserved dish
of spider doctor songs on Spotify put
that out there
anyone that's been too afraid to upload
there is an audience ready she kinda has
this idea that there's a song for
anything so she'll be like seagull song
and inadvertently there will there will
be inevitably yeah so you can't prove
her wrong theory is it stands up yeah
and it's a it's a it's a world I never
wanted to be a part of children I know
I'm so fascinated by this now I'm like
is that my new phase of career work yeah
just start writing cuz you don't really
have to be able to sing no and some of
them are so low quality some low-hanging
fruit they're the children's music
Department I'm just gonna tell you that
that's really good to know if she wrote
a memoir right now how would that go
don't clean my [ __ ] let me change your
diaper I don't know I'm like and every
time I'm like do you want a rash in your
vagina in your butt do you want a rash
it's just like that she's like folklore
yeah haven't happened yet
no it's happened many times oh as a
woman who had 20 employees at once
produced a video a day was be flown
around the world to work on many TV
shows the wiping up but yesterday I had
to wipe a shitty [ __ ] in front of a
closed Sharky's you know the idea of
being a mom in Hollywood has like a
little bit of an elegance to it or just
like I mean from I can't relate so from
my perspective I guess the curated
online persona of people that are doing
it all infuriates me I mean those are
people who have people to handle them
sure honestly some people's instagrams
feeds I'm like you have a staff in there
you have a photo of photography have a
photographer on staff no makeup and hair
on staff you must have five nanny
uh-huh you have a glossy you I mean it's
just you have an estate yeah I don't
have the pay grade for any of that or
the patients if somebody tries to do my
nails I'll punch them in the face so you
literally still do it all I mean I I
have scaled higher in the
sort of like oh you need a lot of people
and I'm sure you had this we all have
peaks and valleys and I didn't
understand this but you got to go up and
then you go down you go up and you down
and like the ones where I was like oh I
have a PR person and I handed in this
agent manager PR person assistant like
it is annoying yeah it feels a little
it's overwhelming and it just it I
always felt too much pressure added to
like so much pressure my creative
experience that's like yeah I got a
support this is these seven people yeah
and they're all just sucking up to me
because I'm paying them you know I
always forget like this isn't a real
human look at connection and the
paycheck stops it's like but he you know
really I mean actually friends with a
lot of my older boys as probably I
wasn't a good boss but that's an
impossible thing that's the one thing
that I I could never scale up like that
because I don't know how to manage
people and like in that world I don't
even know how you even learn other than
just by doing no you're just trial by
fire unless you're raised in it and
that's why when you see like oh there's
a son or a daughter of a famous person
they have a leg up well you know they're
kind of in this everybody else's boat
but they've seen how it works like I
came from a very poor family and it was
a military family I thought a goodwill
toy was like that was exciting you know
and I moved here with nothing right so
anything I've gotten is a blessing yeah
and I don't necessarily value money I'm
certainly not stylish girl no I saw your
tweets about fall colors I got excited I
did I mean I do like a good jewel tone
uh who doesn't I was just so pale any
color no sheet I'm like a white wall
like put a color on me if you've got to
put white here it's like where'd she go
don't worry it's after Labor Day so
you're safe now
is that a rule isn't it no wait after
Labor Day supposedly I don't know why
voyage to the stars oh we're talking
about that yes yeah that's so cool it's
a really apakah so why aren't you
guesting on it well I won for people
that don't know what this is it's like a
sci-fi improv based comedy podcast yes
yeah how does that even work in the
world of podcasting like that blows my
mom so we
a script so we got to know what's going
on in the episode and then each section
is like a log okay and then we will have
like a beginning middle and end so it'll
be a paragraph like this is what happens
in here and then you as a character will
be like okay I'll so really once Tucker
to go off planet god and then at the end
make sure to drop in that your parents
are somewhere so then we will have like
two or three story points but it's just
like three lines and then we go and then
we record for 30 minutes and they cut it
down later so we just so cool yeah so
there's no dialogue that we we just do
improv you would be so good at you
should come do this super-fun how did
that get started that was my friend Ryan
Koppel who is actually I picked him off
of the internet one day back in the day
when I did the guild I would just search
for people who I thought were really
cool a talented and I'll just be like
hey friend because I don't have other
friends he became a really good friend
of mine then he ran production for me
I'm a he became he worked for me from
geek and sundry he had a production that
he ran the company and then he left and
then two years went by and then we were
like hey we work really well together so
we actually have a company together nice
after he started doing voyage I was like
oh so I he asked me to do voyage and
then I'm like oh we work well together
so we're working on a bunch of projects
together right now
sweet it feels like such a cool
interesting way to use podcasts in like
a new way yeah I mean I like I think we
both really love scripted content we
love nerdy Jarra more calmer content and
so this I mean I am so admiring of him I
think this is a really pioneering format
and I think as an improviser like I've
done improv since I first moved to LA I
love it but you know a lot of improv is
not very exciting to listen to because
it's kind of meander II sure and so now
we have like a beginning and an end and
we just make up as funny stuff in
between and then they edit it you know
they edit it down that's awesome though
yeah very big come on
I would love to yeah I'm even though
improv scares me at this point but I'd
be so so down because it just started
second season yes it just said it is
sexist even it was started second season
September 17th and we're rolling out I
think 26 episodes so it's like a whole
you know very a lot of episodes and then
we have some really good guest stars
like Angela Kinsey and Aspen's Nunez
from the office yeah Jesse Cox my
friends
you know who's like a streamer and they
called Paul Tompkins oh no it's like the
improviser so yeah the great Gress stars
it's really fun that's awesome that's
super cool a lot of people want to know
well I want to know what do you do for
fun what what do you do for fun know
what fun for the time when you're not
taking care of your daughter
or working earning or maybe sleeping I
mean my favorite thing to do is travel
yeah and so I can't do that was a kid
yeah just can't have you have you taken
has she been on a plane yet
oh no she's been on plane dozens o times
cuz the first two years I took her
everywhere I went was I was
breastfeeding and it is just horrible to
get milk out of your tits okay I will
just tell you there now it's a year I'm
good it's wonderful and I'm like so
proud of myself if I could just make
food from my body it's wonderful and
it's like great it just was really hard
to get going and then when I got it I
was like oh I'm staying here for two
years I fed her with my breasts Wow is
that too graphic no that's just the most
natural part of life you have them yes
defeats the reason I think most of us
are alive right now
and so after after two I was like bye
she hasn't flown this year okay I will
fly her I will take her with me after
but I do book tour so yeah because
you're coming up this episode will air
after you've done or maybe towards the
end of the book tour yeah are you
excited because you you're lat your
first book came out in what 2015 18 yeah
so it's been four years I know it's a
lot I'm really excited I just I wrote
this book because people really liked my
memoir and some of the things they took
away from it where it's like oh yeah I
started creating cuz you or I got help
for my anxiety because of you so I was
like oh that sounds more useful than
doing another Hollywood pitch that no
one by you know in general 100% so I was
yeah that's the whole point so I really
hope that people enjoy it and I'm kind
of excited to go on tour it'll be the
longest I've been away from her it's two
weeks so uh so it's kind of hard cuz
she's now can't talk and she's like mama
I go with you so she knows what's
happening yeah oh no
blissfully unaware anymore she's like a
little meat sacks she's really fun like
yeah so it's gonna be a little tough but
when I get back it'll be fine she'll
forget it right right that's how babies
work that's what two-year-olds work
right that's how my brain works
correctly and I know I'm gonna be 34 so
good okay we're gonna take one last
break when we get back we have a bunch
of Twitter questions for you so we write
back more not too deep too deep
Black Friday Small Business Saturday
Cyber Monday all made-up days designed
to get you to buy more stuff so let me
tell you about another made-up day it's
called sell your [ __ ] Sunday yep
sell your [ __ ] Sunday it's a day to sell
the stuff you don't use anymore
created by Macari you know Macari the
selling app that makes selling your
stuff fast and easy so here's what you
do you go through your home you find all
the good stuff that you don't use
anymore you know the phone in the drawer
the jeans that you wore one time the
handbag that's in the back of your
closet you take a few pictures add a
description boom your item is connected
to a million buyers it's super easy
Macari even emails you a shipping label
when it sells the app has over 500,000
reviews on the App Store with an average
4.8 star rating so why not give it a try
finally an app that makes you money
check out Macari and make every day sell
your [ __ ] Sunday the day may be made up
but the money is real that's mercury M
ER C AR I the selling app to do if there
is something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals better help online
counseling can help you out they offer
licensed professional counselors who are
specialized in issues like depression
anxiety relationships trauma anger
family conflicts LGBTQ matters grief
self-esteem and more connect with a
professional counselor in a safe and
private online environment get the help
at your own time and at your own pace
everything you share is completely
confidential it's so convenient you can
scheduled secure video or phone sessions
as well as chat and text with your
therapist and if for some reason you're
not happy with your counselor you can
request a new one at any time for no
additional charge best of all it's
affordable and you will get 10% off your
first month with the discount code grace
so get started by going to better help
calm slash grace then fill out a simple
questionnaire that helps them assess
your needs and match you with the
counselor that you'll love again better
help calm slash grace okay we're back
I'm pretty you answered these at the
last time you were on an episode of not
too deep but we're gonna present them to
you again the two questions that I ask
every single guest I got them perfect I
forgot what your answers were so we're
all we're on an even playing field the
first question I ask every guest is who
alive or dead would you most want to
throw cold spaghetti at Oh a cold
spaghetti mmm-hmm I mean I guess you'd
have to interpret it is it a fun playful
thing to do it's it's your and I'd like
to get it in Donald Trump's hair is a
little sticky so it's hard rule he
probably has texture issues as well as
moral issues yeah I can see that in my
mind's eye okay the other question is to
tell us your worst pant shooting story
or close call but you can only use three
words or three small phrases so mine is
college jogging front lawn it has to be
yesterday diapers shitty sharky it was
so traumatic I can't tell you because
she had a bag around her vagina because
we needed to capture her pee to take it
to the doctor because she might have it
like a does something going on down
there so like she had a bag like it's a
heaven I guess they have a sticker bag
to put around your vagina to catch pee
because babies don't know how to pee on
command I don't know how this works and
that all the crap shot everywhere inside
the bag around the bag
up and then I had the luck diaper on
loose so then her skirt got into hot she
loves her skirt so she wouldn't see me
take it off so I'm wiping a skirt
oh it just gets worse it was somebody on
the Sharky's and sure thank God there
was the truck keys was close they got
yeah that was the best part of the story
he was sharkish for giving me an L clove
on a private public street to wipe a
baby's butt hole Oh God alright let's go
and view sort of the questions the first
one is how's life going now that you're
a mom but I think is she oh what's your
guilty pleasure subreddit oh it was the
skincare one what's that I can't
remember the name of it are anyway it's
the one where I just learned slug in it
well I hope you heard of slug you know
so I probably this is the wrong
demographic when you get older and your
skin starts to dry up as your soul does
as well yeah tell me I'm dry husk of a
woman nothing that old but anyway
Internet terms
iíve read about I've just really dry
skin because like especially like just
having weeding the baby and like just
having Monell issues and like it's
better now but anyway my skin is dry as
ass and especially when I fly it gets so
dry yeah so I guess the whole thing on
the reddit was like slugging it is
putting on top of your products uh-huh
you put either aquaphor or Vaseline I
was like Vaseline on your face but then
my dad's a plastic surgeon I was like
he's like yeah that's an occlusive it it
basically seals in moisturizer and so
what I did was I started putting it over
my products now if you have any any acne
prone things do not do this that's okay
if you're gonna break out don't do it
but I put it only under I put it like on
my cheeks and under my eyes it had got
rid of everything lightly smooth baby
but like and this is all because of this
reddit that you saw yeah I saw it on
there yeah well dang alright so the
Internet is super helpful but also like
a pleasure okay someone says what's a
moment she had recently that made her
love being a mom I feel like this is the
opposite so I had a really bad day of
meetings and I'm just like I don't want
to do with my life and she came up and
was like mama I love you just the way
you are
like just she's too random not sure no
she is it's her the emotional
intelligence
it's like above that's a little creepy
like other babies are like I'm a baby
it's just like mother I've been thinking
that you seemed a little stressed out
about your work opportunities and I
wanted to reassure you that you are in
fact loved in this household I was like
I just paid for therapy for somebody
tell what was her first word it was mama
oh she's kind of obsessed with me guys
that's so cute
it's almost no what is a made-up
profession that you'd love to have oh
you've been talking about what going to
Portugal yeah it would be a Portugal
astronomer gaunt maker so you make
croissants for the nighttime when you're
gonna get the stuff look at the stars in
our field like what flavor should I make
tomorrow maybe like guava yeah I think
that's an underserved market right
because I think if we do that in LA I
would sell out just like that moon dust
yeah what was that was that that goop
product yeah that was like the moon
still there there's okay someone's know
which community or show has the best and
kindest fandom do they differ for you I
mean yeah I feel like you know I mean I
think they're all unconditional okay no
cuz some fandoms especially in the video
game world I would say that there are
certain sub fandoms that are like you're
not a nice you're not a nice fandom yeah
I will not specify any because I don't
want any trolls to come over here it
would be shocked if they listen if they
do it's only flattering yeah but I love
actually the supernatural community is
really incredible because I think you
know the guys spear had a lot of charity
yeah and so charity and doing outreach
and community building and supporting
each other around depression and anxiety
and all that Misha Collins especially
and Jared they really just do a lot of
advocacy I think of they really I mean
they do conventions every weekend and
it's like how they're for ten years
they've done this and it says the world
the army kind of they've built up over
the round around the world this like
means a lot to people and so yeah
there's a ton of questions about
Supernatural like did you
any idea that your character would be so
loved like how are you think like is it
coming back is like everyone's very
concerned
well there's one season left y'all they
are ending it after 15 and that's a lot
of people want to know your feelings on
that
I mean I'm sad I cried yeah I mean it
really I've been on that show eight
years so I went I went dark for two
years
yeah and then I came back and I'm I'm
really hoping that I get to come back
the season I I cannot assure you of
anything right but we will see they're
bringing a lot of people back so we'll
see but yeah like even walking on set if
feels like that's the home it's like a
home for me and you guys shoot that in
Canada it's in Vancouver okay yeah I
always like for the last 10 years I've
only flown to work as an actress I
actually got a job on the rookie earlier
this year and driving to work was so
weird I would say am I gonna go see the
car I Drive yeah weird I'm in a car I'm
not being driven by a teamster that's
really nuts but that yeah a lot of
people are asking about that and like
very sentimental about it I didn't
realize that they had a convention every
weekend I mean they do only their
exclusive conventions too so I do a lot
of big ones but I do those too as well
and ya know it's like a tight knit they
were they're really small conventions
too they're like I have 600 people at
the most that's nice though it's
intimate yeah so you see the same people
all the time and like people just
especially go to party so oh yeah it's
actually great that's really sweet
someone to know how is your relationship
with Twitter going what do you think
about Twitter lately I it's it's exactly
how I'm expressing it right now
confusing to create an actual sentiment
about it that is articulate it's
confusing to me and I need to reprogram
how I asked for questions for the
podcast so I feel like I asked on
Twitter and then I forget that Twitter
is like sometimes terrible and sometimes
it is unfortunately like my go-to for
news yeah but it's only because I'm just
conditioned now to look at Twitter
moments all the time yeah use that it's
like this is the thing I should be
knowing about I mean it's good you mean
at least you're not just because I only
look at my political feeds which is just
like rain forest burning children being
caged that's what I saw your very
political on Twitter
and I think that's really interesting
because I go and peaks and valleys of
that on the air because I feel like it's
met with criticism when you try and like
do something help course of course and I
did temper that a lot in the past yeah I
mean I think that I just had some
hot-button topics where I'm just like
girl unless you're using your platform
for a little good and good meaning like
they're just things that I think are
unacceptable right they're being done in
their government in our world and and so
if I alienate like oh I'm sorry a butter
company doesn't want to sponsor me
because I'm too controversial like take
your butter money and shove it up your
behold okay I'm okay not having that
endorsement and I think you know I do
see some people and especially like I've
had this I did a lot of fundraisers over
the last couple years against like the
situation at the border who's visually
regard to children you know literally
our government has two-year-olds going
on trial to defend themselves to not get
too deep sorry I'm getting do but
there's the video I've watched the
videos are they cry yeah these children
don't know don't even speak the language
they don't know what and they're
literally on trial and the judge has to
rule whether they're gonna get sent back
or not so it's crazy yeah and it's not
changing it's just getting worse so I
reached out to a lot of people to hey
come and do a fem raise where we ended
up raising several hundred thousand
dollars amazing but a couple people like
I can't talk about political stuff my
fan base doesn't like it and I'm like so
if you need to marginalize your beliefs
and this is the slow creep I think we
talked about a little bit in social
media like I can't be myself because I
will annihilate some people that are by
business right at a certain business
you're important your business becomes
your identity right and therefore you
stand for nothing because then
everything that they preach about
authenticity which is like these are
your real viewpoints and like opinions
about it gets watered down if you're
hiding that behind the scenes so that
you can hawk some like brand deals it's
actually I'm saying oh yeah I'm gonna be
Jen you know like like totally Swiss
neutral on all political stuff I don't
think in this climate right now that
you're doing you or your world a service
true and like if I'm gonna dig in on
certain things I don't know how you
could be really like I'm very against
global warming like I'm just really
against it guys yeah I don't need that
person as a fan like just quite frankly
I don't mean to be a jerk we just don't
guys yeah your your viewpoints don't
align and it's probably best for both of
you to part ways
I will open a croissant to support
myself thank you but you know I think
once I started doing that was very
painful
yeah I mean I got like really I went
through a horrible trauma with gamergate
like a lot of people crawled up it was
very very traumatic and it separated me
from the gaming world a lot yeah as a
profession but it was ultimately fine
because I was anally nating people who
were only conditionally approving of my
behavior mm-hmm and therefore I was I
was late leaving myself behind in order
to be okay with them so I I was quite
after the trauma kind of faded it made
me a lot more able and kay I know that
I'm capable of supporting myself no
matter what yeah and therefore I will be
able to invest better in the people who
I want to hang out with in my community
if it's a smaller community it will be a
better quality community because we
don't allow that kind of like trolling
and attitude yeah I'm not saying that we
need a monolithic like you have to agree
with my political views to be my fan I'm
just saying there are certain topics
yeah that I important to me and if you
can tolerate them and your feet if you
do agree disagree with them that's fine
and if you really don't want to see me
talk about them I'm you know maybe just
to consume my content and not follow me
on Twitter everyone has the option to
consume you however they want the thing
is you feeling sound and resolute in
like the way you're presenting yourself
and your thoughts and feelings like
that's what's going to attract people
regardless of like they're a hundred
percent agreement with every single
thing that you stand as a creator if
you're living this shorter show life how
you get in touch with who you are inside
oh it's a that's more depleting
emotionally than like getting so many
more subscribers or followers because
you're just placating this like system
of beliefs imagine like take it back to
the some of them I mean your videos were
so funny like your first like daily
great like back in the day they were so
like spontaneous and organic and joyful
and like you're just doing this because
you had this human impulse to share
right and now it's like the retooling of
the whole system has changed like that
impulse isn't in me right now so instead
of trying to force that impulse I or
fake that impulse I'm gonna sit back for
a little bit and like and become
something new yeah that's okay right
like that's the struggle dude I'm gonna
follow your book on my artistic
endeavors well
flourishing again even though this
practice is really fun and it's the one
solid thing that's going on
Phylicia this has been so fun thank you
for coming back on the podcast now to
call out the fortune cookie that's been
the elephant in the room I guess on the
podcast gets a personalized fortune
cookie from us to them that they can
open and read oh it's like you know is
it like when you give somebody a
greeting like a birthday card and then
somebody insists that you they read it
in front of you and then you get real
awkward like oh I don't really want to
read this in front you but I guess oh
it's really long okay I'll just read
this five-page letter then you'll just
stare at me while I read it and I guess
I should do big reactions and like
there's no fortunately it's not like
that at all okay all right here we go
I'm unwrapping it's beautiful really
long actually thank you here's a great
idea for your next line of merch jewel
tones and lots of it baby
hell yeah go to the mall now there you
go quick where can people find the book
where can people cuz it's on audiobook
as well and the podcast and everything
that you're up to so you can find voice
the stars at V TTS on all the on all the
socials but then go to voyage to the
Stars on Apple anywhere you get podcast
it's free just download it okay my book
is at Felicia Day book calm and you
could go the book tour dates are
irrelevant to you okay well not you'll
miss me but the book is and the
audiobook are all available right now in
case you haven't already picked it out
yeah it's embrace your beard so check it
out so yeah thank you so much of course
we'll see you guys next time I'm not
cheap goodbye 2deep 2deep 2deep 2deep
whatever struggles you were facing from
depression and anxiety to trauma and
grief better help can connect you with
the professional counselor in a safe and
private online environment it's so
convenient you can schedule secure video
or phone sessions as well as chat and
text with your therapist and anything
you share is completely confidential
best of all it is affordable and you
will get 10% off your first month with
the discount code grace so why not get
started good better help calm slash
grace fill out a questionnaire to get
matched with a counselor that you'll
love today not too deep is a production
of grace helbig incorporated producer
Melissa D months camera operator Katrina
Henning
edited by Shireen Lana unis post
production sound by Chris Henry and an
extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]